hello and welcome to this little
tutorial here on free code camp
i'm thomas weber farq i'm a developer
from sweden and i've
created a few videos for free code camp
now i love free code camp they have a
lot of great stuff so that's why it's
so fun creating videos for them i just
want to say also that
i have my own youtube channel where i
publish weekly videos so search for
vapenfarc or
check out the link down below here and i
also have a site where i have my premium
courses if you want to get more in-depth
knowledge of stuff i do a lot of stuff
on react and gatsby for example
so visit my site if you like my teaching
style and want to support me
so let's get started hey hey what's up
in this video we're gonna create a cool
little
maybe not that cool but a little web
shop with a cart
so it's going to look something like
this because i found this
fake store api where we can get some
data to create this little store so
that's what i'm using here and you can
add stuff to the cart
as you can see and it adds them up here
and then we have the cart button here
and we have these nice little buttons
where we can change the amount and it
will show the total and of course is
this
if this was a real shop you would have a
button here to go to the payment and
stuff like that but i won't do that
and i'm going to use material ui i'm
going to use react query and
typescript and style components for this
one so it's going to be a lot of
learning in this video i think
go back to your terminal and inside
somewhere where you want to have the
application
i have mine in a folder that's called
react shopping cart
so we're going to create our project mpx
create dash react dash app and then we
name our project i think it's going to
be named react
shopping dash cart
yeah then we use the dash dash template
and typescript this is how you set up a
typescript
application with create dragged app and
we press enter
it will take some time so i'm going to
skip this
okay that went well we have our
application and make sure to navigate
inside
of the folder cd react
dash shopping dash cart
clear the console and then we're going
to install our dependencies so first
we're going to use material ui so there
are a couple of things that we need from
that library
i'm going to install the core and also
the icons because i have an icon up here
you can see
in the store that i use for this one
so mpm i at
material dash ui
forward slash core that's the core
library and then we need icons
so at material dash
ui forward slash icons
so that's everything we need for the
material ui and then we're going to
install react query
so mpm i react dash query
so i'm going to clear the console where
one more thing to install and that's the
style components and you may think well
why are you using style components when
you're using material ui
and that is because i don't really like
the way that i style stuff
in material ui i think there's a lot of
great stuff in the library itself
but the styling is in my opinion
not good so that's why i use style
components i will get much
cleaner code instead of using their
internal way of styling things so that's
why
but it's highly opinionated of course so
if you want to use the
internal stuff instead you can do that
but i won't show it in this tutorial
so i'm going to install mpmi styled dash
components
and as we're in typescript land now we
also need to install the types
so we have add types forward slash style
dash components
all right we can open up our code
like this and i'm going to do some
cleanup first we don't need app.css we
don't need app.test
we don't need the index.css not the logo
and not the report web vitals and the
setup tests
so delete those ones and
inside of the index.tsx we can remove
some stuff remove the report web vitals
remove the index we can also remove this
one here
and actually we can't use the strict
mode as we're going to use the drawer
in material ui or we can use it but we
will get a warning
so i'm going to remove strict mode they
haven't fixed that yet
i hopefully hopefully they're going to
fix it soon
it will throw a warning in the console
so for now i just remove it
and inside the app.tsx file we can also
do some cleanup you can see that this
one is grayed out and that's because we
don't need to import react
when we're using react 17 and above as
we use now
so we remove that then we remove the
logo and we also remove this one
and here we can just remove everything
that has to do with a header
and we can say start i like to have an
arrow function so i'm going to
convert this one to an arrow function
you can do whatever you want
something like this save it and i'm
going to do one more thing before we
start up the application to see that it
works
so we have something to start from and
that's inside of the index.tsx file
we're going to set up react query so
i'm also going to bump this one up
maybe like this so we import
query client and something that's called
query client
provider from react-query
right then we're going to wrap this app
with the query client provider
and it takes in a prop that's called
client
and this client is going to be something
that we create here so we have a const
we can call it client and we create a
new query client
and we call it like this and this will
make sure that we have a client in this
const
so we can provide this client to the
client
client to the query client provider
oh long names here and i'll move the app
inside of this one and this will make
sure that we can use
react query in our application so i save
the file
and then i go back to my console and i'm
going to type in mpemstart
yeah i already have my other application
running on port
3000 so this one is going to be on port
3001 instead
so i'm gonna open up that here localhost
and i'm gonna move it here so this one
is the application we're working on and
we also have the
finished application there so it seems
to be working just going to check the
console
great so that's the setup we're going to
move on and create the
different items for the shop itself and
then lastly we're going to create the
cart and items for the cart
all right we're going to be inside of
the app.tsx file and first we're going
to start with some imports or it's
actually
quite a lot of imports we need for this
one so first we're going to import
use date from
react then we're going to import
use query from react query
and then we have some components so i
marked them with components
and i'm going to import some stuff from
the material ui that we're not going to
need yet but i'm going to import them
now so that we have them later
so first i'm going to import a component
that's called
drawer from
at material ui forward slash
core forward slash drawer
capital d all right then i'm going to
import
something that's called a linear
progress
from at material ui forward slash
core forward slash linear progress
then we have the grid so import grid
from
at material ui forward slash core
forward slash grid
and we're gonna have the icon for the
shopping cart import
add shopping cart
icon from
at material dash ui forward slash
icons forward slash add
shopping cart
yeah add shopping cart and then we have
a badge
so import
badge from at
material ui forward slash core
badge
so that's everything in this component
that we need from the material ui
library we're also going to import some
other stuff here later for example the
cart and the item
so that's what we're going to do later
and we're also going to have some
styling for this one
so i'm going to mark this one with
styles and for now
i'm just going to scaffold out the style
component and i like to keep them in a
separate
file so i'm going to create a new file
that i called app.styles.ts
and in this one i'm going to import
styled from style components
and i just scaffold out the component
that i call wrapper
so i have to export it as i want to
import it in my app
export const wrapper equals style.div
save it and go back to the app.tsx and
now we can import it
import wrapper from
dot forward slash app.styles
and that's our import for now
and as i told you i'm gonna use an api
that's called fake store api i haven't
heard of it before i just googled some
stuff because i needed
a fake store api for this application so
that's what i'm going to use
so we have to create a fetching function
for it so go back to the code
outside of the app itself i'm going to
create this fetching function because we
don't need to
recreate it on each render so const get
products
equals and this is an async function as
we're going to fetch
from an api i'm going to wait
and have parentheses and i wait again so
this
weight inside of the parenthesis is
going to be for the api call itself and
this the weight is going to be when we
convert it to json
because converting to json is also async
so a weight fetch i have a string with a
url https for column forward slash
forward slash
fake store api dot com forward slash
products like this and here at the end
after the last parenthesis i have dot
json and convert it into json
so that's why i have the double weights
we're also going to type this one
the data that we get back from the api
has a structure of it and as this is
typescript we want to
type that structure so this structure
that i'm going to type now i can mark it
with types
is from the api and we're going to see
this structure when we get the data back
so i'm going to export this type because
i'm going to use it in other components
also
i call it car item type
and i specify my type so the id is going
to be a number
the category is going to be a string
the description is going to be a string
the image is going to be a string
the price is going to be a number
the title is going to be a string so
this is all the properties that we get
back from the api but i want to add my
own property and that's the amount
because we need to keep track of the
amount in our cart
so i add the amount and i type this as a
number
so that's the types so now we can type
the return type
of this get products function so colon
and this is a promise as we're using
async and
weight and the promise is what's called
a generic in
typescript so we can provide it with the
type that we want
so promise and then we have angle
brackets
and inside angle brackets we specified
the type that we created up here
cart item type
so there you have it that's the correct
type for the get products function
all right i think we're ready to go to
actually fetch some data
so inside our app we're going to use
react query
to fetch our data so i create a const
either structure out the data
the boolean that's called is loading and
the error
equal and i call the use query hook
and this one we can also type the return
type of the data that we get back
because this use query is also generic
so we have angle brackets
and we type it as the same type
card item type
and this is an array and actually this
one should also be an array up here
i missed this one because the data that
we get back is an array
with all the card items so we specify
this as an array also
all right so that's the type for the use
query then we have the query key and
it's a string we can name it to whatever
we want
i name it products and then
this is getting quite long here we have
our fetching function here
so we have the query key a comma and
then we provide it with a function
get products like this do some order
formatting
we'll place it on its own row and this
should be get products
that's the function that we created up
here and now we can actually console.log
out some data to see
that we get something console.log data
save the file go back to the application
reload it you can see that we have the
data here
and here's the structure that i typed in
my type the category description id
image price title and you can see that
it missed
that amount prop that i added myself
but otherwise it looks exactly the same
when i specified i typed i first looked
at the data and then i know the type so
i could
create that type for it all right so we
know that we have some data
we're just gonna scaffold out some stuff
here before we create our jsx
we're gonna have a few functions inside
of this one we're gonna have a function
that's called get total
items and for now i just create an empty
arrow function we're going to return
null for this one
and we're going to have one that's
called handle add to
cart and i also specify it as an empty
error function
and the last one is going to be handle
remove from cart
and i return now and of course we're
going to return back to these functions
later
all right and before we return the data
the actual data with the products we can
check if
is loading and if we load in something
we can return
from the material ui library we have
something that's called a linear
progress
we also have a circular progress if you
want to have that
that one is a little bit more tricky to
get
centered in the screen so this one is
going to be displayed at the top
and i'm going to show you that in a
second
and also if we have an error we can
return something return
a div that says something
went wrong something like this
save it go back to the application and
we reload it
you can see this progress bar here when
we load the data
so i think it actually looks kind of
nice to have it up here at the top
like this otherwise you could have a
circular progress in the middle here or
something
and that's of course the linear progress
that we imported up here before
from the material ui core
so we have some data and we need to to
create our grid with the products
but first we actually want to create a
component for the grid itself because if
we look here
we have these nice little cards it's
going to be a separate
react component so we can create that
one first so inside our src folder
we're gonna create a new folder that we
call item capital i
and inside this one we're gonna have two
files we're gonna have the item itself
so item.tsx and we're also going to have
a file that's called
item.styles.ts and that's because i want
to have my styles outside of the
component itself
so inside items.styles we're going to
import styled
from style components
and for now i'm gonna export const
i call it wrapper again and it's gonna
be a style div
and we have double back ticks like this
so we're going to fill this in with
styles later but first i want to create
a component itself so go inside of the
item.tsx file
and up here we're going to import
the button from at material ui forward
slash core
button
then we're going to import those types
that we created in this app component up
here so that's why i export them here
so that we can reduce them in other
components so i marked this one with
types
and i import card item
types type without an s
from dot forward slash
app and then we have the styles
import wrapper from
not forward slash item dot styles right
that's every
input we need to do and we're in
typescript so we have to type some props
for this one
type props because it's going to take in
two props
we have the item itself and that's why
we imported this one here this
item prop is going to be of the type
card
item type and then we're going to have
the handle
add to cart
that's going to be the function in the
app here
this one handle add to cart
and we could actually change this one a
little bit now
this handle add the cart is going to
take in an item
i call it clicked item and it's going to
be able to type cart
item type like this so you can see the
type here if we hover over
handle add to cart we have the type here
it will only accept this type so that's
why we also have to type this correctly
in the prop in the item.tsx so this type
is going to be
clicked item and it's going to be of the
type cart
item type and it's going to return
nothing so it's going to return
void so this is the correct type that
one
and then we can create our component
const
item it's going to be a colon and it's
going to be a react
dot fc that's the type for the react
functional component
and this is a generic so we have the
angle brackets
and we give it the props so this is how
you specify and type the props
in a typescript react component
all right then we have an equal sign
parenthesis
with the structure of the props the item
and the handle
add to cart and then we have an error
function and we can make an implicit
return because we're only going to
return jsx in this one
so first we have the wrapper like this
i'm going to have the image so imd the
source
is going to be from the item dot image
we can set an alt on this one and we set
it to the item.title
and these are the properties from the
data in the item that we get back from
the api of course
then we have a div i'm going to have an
h3 tag with the item dot
title and as we're in jsx i have to use
curly brackets to grab these
values then we have a p tag
i have a new pair of curly brackets and
i'm going to grab the item.description
then we have another h3 tag for this one
and first i'm going to have a dollar
sign because the price is going to be in
dollars
and then i have a pair of curly brackets
and i grab the item.price
like this and then we need to
export default item
and yeah of course we need to have the
button also for adding to the cart
so down below here where after the after
the div
we have the button we're going to have
an on click on this one
we have an inline arrow function and we
call the handle
add to cart and we give it the item and
i need to have an inline arrow function
here because we need to send in
this little prop here to this one also
so that's why
we can't just do it like this because
this will trigger it right away
so that's why i use an inline function
you can also create a function up in the
component if you want to do that
but in this case i think it's neat to
have this little inline arrow function
it will be fine so the button
we close it and it's going to say add to
cart
so there you have it this would be this
component
we're going to style it but first i want
to see if our data works
so i'm going to go back to the app.tsx
up here i'm going to import my component
import item from dot forward slash
item and forward slash again an item
then i go down here and in our jsx in
our return statement here
i'm going to create parentheses and
first we're going to have a wrapper
like this and inside a wrapper we can
map through our data
and see if this works so first we're
going to have a grid so i use the grid
component from material ui
this is the container so i mark it with
a container prop and i'm going to set
the spacing
to 3 and then we're going to have a grid
item inside of this one and this is the
item that we first have to map through
our data and create the grid item for
each
item in the data so i have curly
brackets
i have the data i use a question mark
because it's going to complain otherwise
if it's undefined so if you use a
question mark it will just return
undefined
if it can't find the data
dot map we map through the data
then we have the item and we know that
this item is going to be
a card item type card item type
i don't think actually that we need to
specify this because it is
already specified
it already knows that this data will be
of the type card item type or undefined
so i try to not set it at all
yeah it seems to be working so we we map
through the item
and i'm gonna make an implicit return
because we're returning
jsx only so i have parentheses and then
i have a grid
item again from the material ui i marked
this as an item
not the container that i did there i set
the key
to the item.id because we're mapping
through stuff in react and we need to
have a key
and then you can set how this is grid is
going to be structured on different
viewports
so the extra small is going to be set to
12.
small medium is going to be set to 4.
this is quite similar to the bootstrap
if you have used bootstrap before so we
have the grid
and then inside the grid i'm going to
use my item component that
that i just created and we give it the
item prop
we give it the item
and then we have the handle add to cart
it's going to be the function handle add
to cart and then i self close this one
do i dare to save it go back to my
application
yeah you can see that we have our items
here but it looks like crap and that's
because i haven't styled it yet
so that's what we're going to do go back
to the application and inside the
items.style
in the items folder we're gonna style
this
little sucker
okay so we have the wrapper so first
we're gonna display it
as a flex not full screen edit
why did it say like that yeah that's
because
this one disappeared display
flex i'm going to justify the content
to space between
i'm going to set the flex direction to
column
the width is going to be 100 percent
the border is going to be one pixel
solid and light
blue the border radius
is going to be 20 pixels maybe and the
height is going to be 100
and then we're going to style the button
so we can
specify it inside of the wrapper here
that's so great with style components
you can nest
stuff like this i'm going to set the
border radius
to 0 0 20 pixels and 20 pixels and i'm
going to
explain that why later
then we have our image so we style the
imd
the max height is going to be 250 pixels
the object fit is gonna be cover
and the border dash radius is gonna be
20 pixels
20 pixels zero zero and the last one
we're gonna style is the div and we can
check it out here we have a div here
inside also so we're going to style this
once
so back to the item styles the div
the font family is going to be ariel
not font font family font family
ariel i set the padding
to one rem and i set the height
to 100 percent and hopefully when we
save this and go back to our application
you can see that it looks a lot better
now
and this if you see here when i click
the button you can see that i style the
corners
otherwise this one here will go over the
corner of the card itself so that's why
i set the border radius
on the bottom and i think it looks
pretty nice and you can see that it
restructured itself now on small
viewports
so you can tweak this yeah maybe a
little bit better if you want to do that
i think you get the id here on how stuff
can look
so that's the items and we're going to
continue on creating the cart
next so we have this nice little icon
here to show and hide the court and
we're
going to add some stuff to the court and
do some calculations and stuff like that
the first thing we're going to do is to
scaffold out some stuff in the app.tsx
file and up here at the beginning of the
app component
i want to create a few states that we
need for our cart
it's a const cart open
set cart open or you can call it
cart is open or something if you want to
do that because this is going to be a
boolean
that telling us if the card is open or
closed equal
use state and we set it to false
initially
then we need a state with actual items
that we have in our cart
so const card items
items with an s set cart
items equal use state
and this one is going to be an array and
we have to type this one i want to set
it to an empty array initially so i
create an empty array and then i specify
the type
s cart
item type like this and this will create
the correct type if we hover
over here you can see that this is the
card item type it's an array of card
item type
so that's the states that we're going to
need for this one
and then we can scroll down here
just at the beginning of the wrapper
inside of the wrapper
we're going to create our drawer and
that's a component from the material ui
drawer it takes a prop that's called
anchor
and we want it to be anchored to the
right of the screen
open that's going to equal the state
that we created
cart open state up here that we just
created
so it's going to flip between true and
false
shouldn't be a coma there
and then we have a prop on close so we
have an inline arrow function
set cart open
and we set the value to false then we
close it like this and inside of drawer
we're gonna have our cart we haven't
created that component yet
so we can just type in cart goes here
like this then we need our open and
close button for the cart
and for this one i actually want to
style this button a little bit so i'm
going to show you a different way of
styling the button
last time for the item i styled the
button like this
but you can also style a button by
providing it to the style component
itself
so inside our app.styles file
we're going to create a new style
component and for this one the wrapper
we can actually just
set the margin to 40 pixels for that one
that's the only style that we're going
to need i just give it some
morgan so it won't go to the edges of
the screen
and then we create a new component
export const
i call it style button
equal style and then we can provide this
function instead of doing backticks and
creator styles
we can have a parenthesis and provide it
with a component that we want to style
so i'm going to import something that's
called an icon button
from material ui so from
at material dash ui
forward slash core forward slash icon
button
and then i can provide this icon button
to the style component like this
and then we have the regular backticks
for styles
and we can type in our style just as we
always do with the style components
position is going to be fixed
the set index is going to be 100 we want
it to be placed over the other content
we set it to right 20 pixels
and top 20 pixels and as usual you can
tweak these values if you want to do
that
so we save the file go back to our app
component
and we can create our button so just
below the drawer
now first we have to import it of course
so up here
where we have the styles wrapper we're
also going to import the styled button
like this then we move down here
just below the drawer
we can use the style button and this is
now a button element or an icon button
from the material ui so we can use the
same props as usual we can use it
just as a regular button from the
material ui
so an on click handler an inline arrow
function
set card open and we set it to true
when we click this button
and this button is also going to have
something that's called a batch if we
look at the finished application i have
this
red little badge here that shows how
many items there is in the cart
and we're already importing this as we
did before so we can use this badge now
from material ui
so badge the badge content
and we have created a function for this
but it's empty now
but it's the get total items
and we give it the card items then we
set the color
to error and that will make it red
and then inside of here we have our add
shopping cart
icon that we imported from material ui
also
you can see here that typescript
complains because we haven't specified
that this function has a parameter so we
can't send in an argument to it
expected zero arguments but got one so
we can
adjust this one so go up here to the
function
this one is going to take in the items
that's all the items so we have the type
of
cart item type and an array
and this will make this arrow go away
hopefully
like this sometimes it's a little bit
slow actually before it
kicks in save the file make sure that it
works
and we have our button here you can see
and it opens the cart
and we can close the cart by clicking
outside of the cart
you can of course add a bottom there if
you want that also
i think this is sweet actually i like
this sidebar from material ui
and no we don't have any items here so
this one will show this badge when we
have the items
so we can actually create this get total
items function now
we remove this null
and i'm just going to put it on the
other row you can have
these curly brackets if you want to have
that and create a return statement but
i'm going to do an implicit return here
as this is an arrow function so it's
going to be a one-liner
so from the items that's the items that
we send into this function
we're going to reduce and first we have
the accumulator
that one is going to be a number it's
going to return the total number
of the items in the cart and then we
have the items
the items is already specified up here
so it will know
that this one is of the type card items
type
right then from the accumulator
we add the item dot
amount and we initialize it with zero
shouldn't say items it should say item
without an s
so this will iterate through all the
items in the cart
and it will use the property amount and
add up the amount and that will give us
the total amount
that's in the cart and the accumulator
we give it an initial value of zero
so that will add up so 30 starts with
zero then it
adds the amount for each item
but it won't show us anything yet of
course because we don't have anything
and we can't actually put something in
the cart
so we're going to see this in action
later
okay so we have the drawer
and we have the button for the card i
think it's time to create the card
itself
so inside the src folder we're going to
create
a new folder that's called cart
and inside of that folder we have a file
that's called cart.tsx and we also have
a file for the styles just as before
card.styles.ts
we can start in the style file we import
styled
from style components like this
then we create our component we're going
to have a wrapper again so export const
wrapper equals a style and this one
isn't a div i think it's more
appropriate to have it as
a side because it's kind of a sidebar
a style on a side element double back
ticks and then i have the css and this
is not much so we can actually do it
already now
i set the font family to arial
i set the width to 500 pixels for my
sidebar
i set the padding to 20 pixels
and this should be it i think save the
file
go back to the cart dot tsx file
and we can start by importing some stuff
as we always do
and also we're actually going to have a
cart item so i think we can create that
one also and just scaffold it out so we
can use it in our cart
so inside src folder create a new folder
cart
item and just as before we have two
files
cart item dot tsx and
new file cart item dot styles
dot ts and we start
in the styles file import style from
style components
we export the const that we call wrapper
for this one also and it's going to
equal
style.div double back ticks and then we
have our css
and i think
yeah no we can wait with the css i'm
just going to
leave this empty for now so save the
file and we go back to the card item
and first we're going to import a button
from
at material dash ui forward slash core
button then
we needed types so import
card item type from
dot dot forward slash app
and then we have the styles
import wrapper
from dot forward slash car item styles
and then we scaffold out this component
const car item is going to be a react.fc
a functional component equal and for now
we leave it
empty like this we can just
create a div that says card item
and we export default card item
and save the file so we're going to come
back to this later of course and create
that component
but for now we go back to our cart and
we can import this cart item
from dot dot forward slash cart item
and cart item
then we have our styles import
wrapper from dot forward slash
cart dot styles and we have our types
import card item
type from dot dot forward slash
app you can see that i also comment here
everything
you don't have to do this actually in a
small application like this but
it's a habit i have when i work on
larger applications that i
i like the common stuff here on the
imports because if you have 20 or
30 imports so you quickly can see what
you're importing
but you can of course remove them like
this if you don't want to have them
because we only do three imports here
right and this one is going to have some
props type props
we have the card items and by now we
know that these are going to be
the card item type and it's an array
because this is the cart
so it's going to receive an array with
all the items that's in the cart
then we're going to have add to cart
that's the function that we created in
app
we know that this one has the type
parentheses clicked item that's the
parameter for that function
and that one is going to be a car item
type
and it's going to return void it returns
nothing
and then we have remove from cart
this one is only going to take in the id
and it's going to be of the number type
and it return nothing because when we
remove something we don't actually need
to add any elements
because we already have all the items in
this array that we're going to
remove from so that's why we only need
the id for that one
okay so that's the props so we can
create our component const cart
it's a react dot fc a functional
component
we have the angle brackets and we give
it the props
because this is a typescript generic so
that's why we can send it in like this
and then we have the props so every
parenthesis with the structure out the
card
items the add to cart
and remove from cart
and we have an arrow function and this
one
is going to make an explicit return so
we have curly brackets
and we have the return statement like
this
so first we return the wrapper that's
the style component we created
then we have an age to tag
your shopping cart
or whatever you want to type in and then
we can also type in some text
if we don't have any items in the cart
so i have curly brackets and i check if
cart items dot length equals zero
then i have a question mark it's a
turner operator i display a p
tag no items in cart
and otherwise we display null we display
nothing
so this will display this text if we
don't have any items in the cart
and then we can map through our items
card items
dot map we have the item we don't have
to
specify the type because it will know
that it's of this type
you can see here card items is of the
card item type so we don't have to
specify it here
like this and i make an implicit return
on this one
and i'm going to return the cart item
and for now
i just do like this we're going to come
back to this one
very important to export default
cart otherwise it won't work so we're
going to come back to this one and give
it the correct props
but for now i'm going to go to the app
dot tsx file and we're going to import
cart from dot forward slash
cart forward slash cart
like this we go down
in our jsx instead of cart goes here
we're gonna use our card component
and you see that it complains because it
wants the props so we have to specify
the props also for the cart
so we have the cart items it's going to
be the cart items
then we have add to cart
it's going to be the handle add to cart
i can actually move them down to their
own row and then we have
remove from cart
it's going to be the handle remove
from cart
save the file and we go back and see
what we got so far
you can see that we have our shopping
cart here no items in cart because we
don't have any items in the cart
all right so we go back to the cart
we know that it's working and this cart
item here we're going to provide it with
the correct props
first as we're mapping through these
items we need to set a key
and the key is going to be the item.id
then we have the item
then we have the add to cart function
add to cart and we have
remove from cart
and remove from cart and now you can see
the complaints because we haven't
created this
item component yet so that's what we're
going to do next because now it
complains and it
breaks the application but keep calm we
will fix this soon
so we are sending in the props to the
card item and we can build our card item
component
so go back to the cart item file
not the styles right now the file here
and we import everything that we need
here and we can create the props for
this one so type
props equal we have the item
it's going to be of the cart item type
this is a single item so we don't have
an array here
and then we have to add to cart it's
going to be the clicked
item and cart item type
and it's going to return void it returns
nothing and then we have remove
from cart this one is going to be an id
with a number and it's going to return
nothing so
void and we give it these props inside
of angle brackets
just here we did before so now you can
see cart
won't complain anymore because we have
the correct props typed for us
so that's sweet and our application
should be working again yeah it is
right back to the code we can still make
an
implicit return but we're going to have
parenthesis here
and we're going to have the wrapper
and first inside of the wrapper we're
gonna have a div
oh what happened yeah
okay like this then i have an h3 tag
and there i'm gonna display the
item.title
insider curly brackets of course because
we're grabbing these items now
and we haven't destructed out the props
i need to do that also it's up here i
just structure out the item
the add to cart and
remove from cart
and this item of course i can show you
in the finished one
is this item here that i create now so i
have the so the h3 tag is going to have
this title and then we have these
buttons to add
and remove stuff here so that's the one
that we create now
all right that's the title then we have
another div
and for this one i'm going to create a
class name it's going to be
information
this one is going to hold a p tag
with price i
have a dollar sign
and then i have curly brackets don't
mistake this for a template literal
because this is just a dollar sign that
i
print out it has nothing to do with
these curly brackets here
i'm going to grab the item.price for
this one
and then we have another p tag we're
going to calculate the total for each
item
so the total is going to be yet again we
have a dollar sign
in front of our price that we're going
to show
and i have a pair of parentheses and i
take the item
dot amount times
the item dot price
and then i need to remove some decimals
so i'm going to have
dot 2 fixed and a 2 that's going to give
us 2 decimals
all right so that's going to be the
total that we can see
if i go back to the application
[Music]
the finished one going to be these ones
here
that we created now and now we have to
create the buttons and the
total amount here
so i create another div with a class
name of
buttons
i create a material ui button
the size is going to be small
i'm going to disable elevation so i
don't have any drop shadow on it
the variant is going to be contained
as i want it to display with a
background in the button
and then i have the on click handler
it's going to be
an inline arrow function
and i'm going to call the remove from
cart
and i'm going to provide it with the
item dot id
now we close the button and inside the
button i'm just going to
type out the minus sign
right then in the middle we're gonna
have a p
tag curly bracket item dot amount
and curly bracket and then we can
actually copy this button here
paste it in below the size is going to
be the same disable elevation and
contain is going to be the same
the on click is going to be
add to cart instead and this one
takes in the complete item not only the
id
so i'm going to remove id and give it
the item
and this one is going to have a plus
sign instead so that's the balance
and then we need to have the image also
and the image is going to go
below the divs here last before the
ending wrapper tag
so i have imd src equal
the item.image and i set an alt
to the item.title on this one we can
self-close it
like this and this should be the item
for the cart
save the file just go back to check that
everything works
it does but we can't see any items
because we don't have any way to
actually add it to the cart so that's
what we're going to do next we're going
to create the function for adding and
removing
stuff in the cart and we're also going
to display the total
amount in the cart
we move back to the app.tsx file the
main component for the application so to
say
and we need to create our functions for
adding stuff to the cart and also
removing
stuff from the cart we already scaffold
out this handle at the cart
so we remove this null create curly
brackets and inside we're gonna do some
stuff
when we click this button we're going to
set
cart items and this is the setter for
the state and we can always get the
previous state from this one
so prev you don't have to call it prev
but i like to call it prev as it stands
for
previous in my mind at least
so we have prayer and then we have curly
brackets i'm going to make an explicit
return on this one and first
is the item already in cart
already added in the cart because we
have to take into consideration here
when you click
add if the cart is empty we need to add
that item to the cart
if it already exists in the cart we
should only add on the amount
on that item so we should modify the
item that exists in the cart
so we can check if this one is in the
cart
and remove the sidebar i create a const
is item or is item
in cart maybe to be extra specific here
from the previous state i'm gonna find
i have the item and i check if the item
dot id
equal to the clicked item
dot id so i check if the item that i
clicked on exist in the cart
by by comparing these two ids i loop
through the stuff
it's going to return true or false if it
finds it in this array
right then if
is item in cart
if we have this item in the cart
we need to do some stuff so if we have
the item in the cart
we need to update the amount on that
specific item
and we can do that by mapping through
the items so return
prev.map
we have the item an arrow function and
we can make an implicit return on this
one
we have the item dot id if that one
equals
the clicked item dot id
i create a turner operator it's going to
be on multiple rows here but i have the
question mark
then if it finds the item we're going to
update that amount
so i return an object with curly
brackets i spread out the old item
and then i have the amount property
i'm going to update this property
item.amount
plus one if we find an item otherwise we
have a colon
and we're just going to return the item
as it is we don't do anything we only
update the amount on the item that we
actually clicked on
so this is if we have an item in the
cart otherwise
we can mark it as first time the item is
added
we're going to return and we have the
array
we spread out the previous state inside
of the array and we add this
new item so we spread out the clicked
item inside of curly brackets we're
creating an object here
and we set the amount to one
so this is hopefully going to add this
item to the cart so i'm going to go
through it again here the first thing i
do is i call the setter
for the card items if we use a function
for the setter we will get access to the
previous state
so i checked in the previous state if
this item already exists because if it
exists
we need to update it instead of adding
it to this
array and if it exists i'm going to loop
through all the items until i
find the item that i clicked on and i'm
going to add one to the amount for that
one
otherwise if this is the first time that
we click on this item to the cart
the first time we put it in the cart i
return an array with all the previous
stuff in the cart
i spread it out here and then i add this
item to the array here
where i spread out the clicked item but
i set the amount to one
so we can see if it works save the file
go back
to the application reload it just to be
sure
i click add to cart and you can see that
it adds it up here
and this actually looks awesome already
but it
doesn't look awesome here it's quite big
we haven't styled this once yet so
that's what we're going to do next we're
going to style this cart item so that's
what we're going to do
now go back to the code and inside the
cart
item dot styles we have this wrapper
first we're going to display it
as a flex we justify the content
to space dash between
we set the font family to ariel
border dash bottom is going to be one
pixel solid
light blue we set the padding
dash bottom to 20 pixels
we can actually see how it looks like go
back to the application yeah we have
some styling here right
then we're going to style the div we set
that one to flex 1
and then we have the class that we call
information
and also the class that's called button
so we style these ones in one go
we display them as a flex and justify
content
space dash between
and then we're going to style the imd
the image
max dash width is going to be 80 pixels
for this one
and we set the object fit to cover
and the margin dash left is going to be
40 pixels
save it go back to the application and
you can see that
yeah it still doesn't look right
we have to fix this
it's some stuff with this one here the
buttons
information i'm gonna go to the cart
item
no it's the bonus class name buttons
yeah buttons with an s change this class
and add an s it should say buttons and
i'll go back and you can see that it
looks great now i think but we can only
add items
and you can see this is what's so great
about reactos we can reuse stuff we have
created this component and we use the
same function
for adding stuff and it just instantly
works
because it's the same function that we
use here
so the thing we have to do now is to
create our function for removing items
in the cart so go back to the code and
inside
app.tsx
we have our function that's called
handle remove from cart
and this one is going to have a
parameter that's called id
and this one is going to be a number we
remove
null create curly brackets
and yet again we're going to set cart
items we have the previous state an
arrow function
we can make an implicit return
and for this one i'm going to use reduce
so i have the prev
dot reduce parenthesis
and another pair of parentheses i have
the accumulator
and i have the item arrow function and i
make an
explicit return on this one i think it's
more readable
we also need to specify the initial
value for the reduce
otherwise typescript will complain for
us so we have a coma
we have an empty array and we're going
to specify this as
cart item type and an array
and then it won't complain for us later
and the first thing we have to do in
this reduce is to check if
if the item dot id equals to the id
if we're on that item in the array that
we clicked on
we're going to do something so we have
curly bracket and we have another if
statement because we want to check if
the item amount is 1
then we're going to remove this item
from the array when we click the minus
sign
because we go from one to zero and it's
no longer in the cart
so if item dot amount equals to one
we're going to return the accumulator we
remove this item from the array
so we only return our accumulator and do
nothing
otherwise we're going to return an array
we spread out the accumulator the
previous array
we create a new object where we spread
out the item
we have the amount and the amount is
going to be
subtracted by one so from the item dot
amount
we have minus one so if we're on the
item that we clicked on we first check
if the amount is one
then we remove it from the array
otherwise we remove
one from the amount and if we're not
on the item that we clicked on we have
the else statement here
we're going to return an array
we spread out the accumulator and we
return the item as it is
we don't do anything with item
and i have some stuff here that is not
correct
[Music]
why is it so i guess
it is yeah this one here
should of course remove the coma and it
should go inside of here
instead like this
so the reduce starts here and then we
have a coma and then you have the array
and we specify it as a card item type
like this so i'm going to go through it
again just to explain
so we set the card items we have the
previous state i call the reduce on the
previous state
we have an accumulator that starts with
an empty array that we specify as the
card item type an array of card item
type
then i check if the item id is equal to
the id here that
gets sent in as an argument to this one
we know that this is the item that we
clicked on
and if the item amount equals to 1 i
return the accumulator so i skip this
item and this will delete it from the
array
otherwise i return a new array where i
spread out the accumulator
and i have a new object where i spread
out the item
and i subtract one from the item amount
so we remove one from the amount
otherwise
we return the item as it is so we have
the accumulator and the item in this
array
right save the file we can go back to
our application and see if it works
and it does and you can see that it
calculates this
beautifully when we remove stuff here
so i'm pretty happy with this we only
have one more thing to do and that is to
display the total amount in the cart
so go back to the code and inside the
cart
that's why we also made an explicit
return here because we're going to
create this function here
so up here at the top of the cart
component
we're going to create a new function
const calculate
total equal it's going to take in the
items
that is going to be of the card item
type and array
we have an error function i make an
implicit return so i move down to the
row below
and the items dot reduce yet again i'm
going to use the reduce
method we have the accumulator
it's going to be a number and we have
the item the item we don't need to
specify because it already knows
that this is for the cart item type so
we have an arrow function
and accumulator and to the accumulator
i'm going to add
the item dot amount
times item.price
and then i have a comma and specify the
accumulator to be zero
initially so we have the
calculate total function and if we move
down here
just below the card items we create an
h2 tag
total colon and then we have the dollar
sign again
just to display it in front of the price
current brackets we call the calculate
total we give it the card items
and this is fine but i want to remove
some decimals on this one also so i have
dot 2 fixed
and i give it a 2 because i want 2
decimals
save the file go back to the application
and you can see the total amount and
there you have it we have a fully
working cart
at least some of it we can't actually
buy something but
yeah you know what i mean so i think
this actually is a good practice because
you can use this
in the real world so to say because this
is not actually far from
a lot of stuff you probably will do if
you work
on a real world application